it's a place where they should have been
safe
but more than 300 girls were abducted
from their boarding school in northwest
nigeria
taken from their dormitories at night
among them were eunice muhammad's four
tell me the daughters we tried to come
by that time
the exchanging fire between that robot
and soldier couldn't give us
time
large groups of armed men operate in
this area
they kidnapped for ransom and nigerian
police and army say
they are now hunting them we're on the
trail of the kidnappers that's why you
find us in the fringes of the forest
here
it's part of our locational efforts
and it's part of our coding cordoning
efforts
it's been nearly eight years since the
terror group boko haram abducted 276
schoolgirls causing global
outrage more than a hundred of them
never returned home
and since then schools have become
common targets for mass kidnappings
just last week 42 people including 27
pupils
were taken from a science college in
niger state
and in december 344 boys were abducted
from a secondary school in northern
katsina state
they were later released but aid
agencies say that the situation is
deteriorating
people are getting used to being able to
undertake something like this the
horrific consequences of not only being
taken
now but the consequences are compounded
by the fact that the parents might not
send their girls back to school if
they're released
and other parents might withdraw their
girls from
school for families of missing girls
an agonising way begins in the hope of
getting their daughters back
milena vassalinovic sky news